forse era tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
queste nomine sono quello lì che fa i
video quello la proprio quello ciccio
game ragazzi l'ultimo episodio fatto
dieci minuti di boltro che tra l'altro
non ne ho fatte 15
devo anche guardare se qualcuno mi ha
battuto perché comunque mondo provate a
battere provate a farvi un video vedere
mettono su youtube vediamo se riuscite
perché alle volte alcuni scrivono un
aiuto battuta e che ne so io mica un
mito ho visto siamo dunque sono natale
per cento impossible già vecchio se ci
fossi riuscito subito se ci avessi
riuscito force i ragazzi non lo puoi
prendere proprio perché non ci arrivi
capito scherzavo forse ci si può
arrivare se se lo prendi un botto di
software
eccolo porca vacca a marcelo con le
bombe alla madonna col demonio
eccolo queste quella cavalca era quello
giusto
devo aspettare un bozzo ce l'avevo fatto
solo non avessi fa colpirla è proprio
lui proprio lui la finisce la completa
fan bold troppe m'ispirano purtroppo a
ok ok perché sono questi questi veli
ragazzino i capi sono quelli veri 2 devi
passare in mezzo alle palle nel vero
senso della parola
e lo devi fare tipo divincolandosi un
casino e vabbè come faccio ma no sono
rigidi questi non ci posso passare in
mezzo è possibile che chi si è inventato
st quando si estremo questa è una cagata
era molto pd era molto più difficile
quello delle palle sinceramente sì ho
tep wyss se passi questo arrivo ce l'ho
fatta il maestro delle fan bold no
perché poi non ho ancora capito il senso
veramente perché lo fanno da un sacco di
tempo però book come i rock swing però
alla fine rossi un po ha senso l'udc è
bellissimo la prima è stata bellissima e
sono caduti tutti di sotto è partito
come il miglior boltro nella storia c'è
anche il caricamento tra l'altro sta
cosa geniale non l'avevo mai vista in un
boltro se non potrò new rock swing sono
fuso ho mai visto il rock singh il
caricamento dei ti fa vedere quanto ci
mette la cosa scendere bellissimo
in tutto questo non ho capito
pato ho rischiato ho rischiato di andare
troppo oltre per ho visto una roma
strana scusatemi in attimo lo rifaccio
perchè ho visto una roba sana che voglio
provare a prendere perché dopo il
traguardo a posto dopo il traguardo
c'era un'altra tra rock
ok dai che ci arrivo non ci sono
arrivato c'era una liana comunque dopo
ho toccato il traguardo non me l'ha dato
per quale motivo la lex ebrei forlan
extreme non c'è niente di estremo per me
soprattutto il bottone cobra dr che di
mio figlio
tizio a me non serve anzi va avanti
grazie luke miei smonta smettila di
smontarli la pista c'è una bottiglia
aveva una bottiglia dovresti tener mio
figlio che mi fa e crea solo peso grazie
io coerente non sono ringraziarti della
tua esistenza ha messo il più utile non
esiste ok tutto a posto raga non ho
offeso il mio figlio tutto bene ok come
ho fatto a perderla vicino ha vinto
anche il sellino manco solo io dai
pirati in avanti tirati ok ok 20 la
manina
sto gioco sta diventando veramente
nonsense fatemelo dire era anche ora
dopo sette anni passati a giocarlo rock
swing vedo l'ora che esca più due per
vedere cosa succede
ma ragazzi ma stanno facendo di rossini
incredibili ma da quando così belli
bellissimo ad ora devo aggrapparmi a sto
coso sicuro c'è bellissimi si rock swing
che oggi proprio qualità eccelsa non so
come mai ciò non avrei fatto rocks in
così fatti bene vi siete svegliati ora
dopo sette anni a fare le nozze infatti
guardaroba c'era mai visto le robe da
geni non rock swing ma di cosa parliamo
ok ok
quando uno ce l'ha nel sangue nel sangue
getting over it
ok ma veramente no ragazzi incredibile
fatto benissimo lo raga nora che hanno
rega non l'ha fatto non credo è fatto
veramente bene e uguale c'è uguale solo
che non lo fai col mouse lo fai con le
frange ma uguale pro giuro non riescono
non riesco è impossibile ma l'hai fatto
tutto norak assurdo non si può fare
perché non puoi ah ah eccolo ci sono
[Musica]
bene e fa è uguale bellissimo bellissima
idea ma cavolo
no loro no ha fatto troppo le ne manca
uno identico non ragazzo emozionatissimo
ha fatto troppo uguale no vabbè genio
questo livello dell'anno dell'anno ma
non vi rendete conto di quanto sei denti
non c'è proprio se fosse col mouse
sarebbe getting over it no è finito già
no mi chiamano tutta la montagna è la
madonna che è successo bellissimo del
bravissimo l'hai fatto oggi ma spero che
arrivi nel podio
l'ho giocato per primo uno dei primi
sono stato a giocarlo ma spero che vine
il podio dei livelli ha fatto benissimo
complimenti bravissimo
speriamo che non faccia lo faccia bello
lungo è veramente figo francese mines
vorrei insomma mi piaceva il nome a stai
attento alle mine compagno ma cosa fare
allora ho già vinto però vediamo un
attimo se andando avanti si può fare
perché magari con la vittoria per gli
scarsi io faccio ma che ne so io dove
sono le mie alle mille soa ok ora so
dove sono le mine gli devo stare più
attento alle mine di è finito rehn
no tutto a posto tutto calco tutto
mescola tutto né tutto qua tutto calato
io avevo già calcolato questa cosa
perché so che questa è la vera roma e
questa è la parte della volta giusta lo
so io lo so fate fare a me fate fare a
me il capitano di brigata tutto a posto
amico mio io sono salvato la vita è nel
senso che ucciso io a me non ti ammazza
le mine bene perfetto ora dopo sono
stato un po lunghi nome mi piaci finito
sopra madonna a questi sarebbero i
nemici attenzione ok ok esplosa pur
lamina vi dovete togliere se non ci
fossero questi avrei già vinto togliti
dalla mia porco demonio di strada però
ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta sono fatte o fatte devi
toglierti non avevo previsto questo in
guerra non si genere non mi succede però
anche in call of duty mi è mai successo
star madonna
sto facendo un casino esce madonna 6 ore
[Musica]
due ore e mezza per arrivare lì che c'è
un morto che misma dai va dai ti devi
togliere ok
[Musica]
avrei fatto molto meglio a farlo prima
però io che gli e 6 ken yes aic n
proprio gli sai che il sacco invece no
io non ken andiamo fare il giro e
centrale ok ma forse si sono ripartiti
all'inizio va bene va bene ok nato piano
piano piano piano piano piano piano
fervet ora sì che sia ora tutto bene
devo riuscire a non cadere nel jazz ad
un po meno meraviglio era di un
parcheggio che in bici po troppo cioè
oltre oggi non ho fatto l'ho fatto solo
mille volte altro giorno ma oggi zero
sono già morto devo capire come si apre
la roba credo credo il verde il regalo
peccato tra l'altro sta maglia dovrebbe
essere un po verde
solo che solo che mi vede attraverso
licei green screen
oddio che effetto strano bellissimo
facciamo l'ultimo ragazzi l'ultimo di
oggi che sarà uno smartphone o un
impossible disposti boldrin d smap a
posto tutto bene tutto bene mi capita
sempre di prendere elfi di babbo natale
in faccia
sono morto ok però ci posso fare lo
sento luke proteggimi la parte esterna
ces non è tutto ok ho solo una spada nel
coccige ma tutto bene madonna ho parato
parato l'arpione non si può vincere
purtroppo è un peccato pro valutiamo
altavista che proprio questo pirata non
si può vincere
però quel bellissimo perché la squadra
mi ha bloccato l'arpione cioè non so
come sia stato possibile
l'ultima dai l'ultimissima poi faccio di
tutti voi change ok no perché è
diventata una sorta di soddisfazione
personale prove di no non si può passare
perché la spada dei bloccati e
impossibile però era una domanda
risposta è no non si può fare brocchi ai
facevano un altro bel valtur nuovo ok
questo è bellissimo
non li vedo molto spesso ma sono
talmente figli del gol ma dobbiamo fare
la prendi tu devi fare parkour ed
evitare tutti gli ostacoli nel mentre
che la palla va avanti e bellissimo era
tipo quel giochino ci abbiamo giocato
tipo rock
cioè tu disegnavi la strada
[Musica]